Welcome.
Thanks for having me.
I bought the ingredients.
I'm borrowing some fridge space.
Okay.
I bought some pudding too,
so let's have that for dessert.
Thank you.
What's wrong?
I was just thinking your place
is cleaner than I expected.
I'll prepare the food now.
Um, okay.
You're amazing.
What's wrong?
Nothing, there's just
not enough air in here.
I'm sorry, though.
Bass isn't very interesting
on its own, is it?
Really?
But I like it.
Huh? What is it?
Something smells real good.
Oh yeah, we have curry, don't we?
Wow, I'm super hungry now, Inui.
Wanna go ahead and eat?
You're right. Let's eat.
I'm Team Curry on Rice. What about you?
Hm... Team Curry and Rice.
You don't say? Roger that.
Can I use your bathroom?
Of course.
Thank you.
Inui, I'm sorry.
I accidentally poured the curry
on top of both.
Hm?
Inui?
-I'm going home.
-What?
What about the curry?
You can have it, Haida.
Once it's cold, you can put it
in the fridge and have it tomorrow.
Wait, Inui.
I'm sorry.
You haven't done anything
to warrant an apology.
It's fine for now.
Please just tell me one thing.
Do you like me?